as freddie peralta
goes to work against the cardinals he is
yet to see saint louis
in his 2021 season saw him a bunch last
year as a reliever as you see mike
schilt in his fourth season
at the helm of the saint louis cardinals
he's got the four-seam fastball he's got
some natural cut to a two at 93 miles an
hour throws a lot of the slider now
that's the new wrinkle that's what he's
been racking up a lot of strikeouts has
a curve ball will makes in a change as
well but it's going to be mainly
fastball slider for peralta
this one is hit in the air and playable
into shallow right and it is going to be
caught
by jackie bradley jr one up and one down
here in the cardinal first inning runner
goes 3-2 ground ball hit the short
urease goes the short way
safe there throw to first is going to be
in time to get goldschmidt
risky play by urias to try and get the
out at second carlson beat that and then
carlson did the smart thing and stayed
standing to try and obstruct the vision
of colton wong he was off and running he
had a pretty good jump against freddie
peralta ball was hit for a double play
if he's not having that kind of a jump
the pitch
swinging a liner to right should be and
will be caught
by jackie bradley jr
on a wicked line drive aronado lines out
to end the inning
cardinals leave one stranded and there
is
kim chris he is going to nibble at those
edges as much as possible and never give
in one ball to no strikes and this one
lined to the gap in left center long run
get up on that wall it is
in the second base
goes colton wong
with a leadoff double and the brewers
are in business here
against his former mates he goes the
other way into the gap out there forcing
fastball elevated love how the head was
buried able to get the arms extended he
does such a nice job of staying square
to the plate as lorenzo kane digs in
kane swings and misses he goes down on
strikes on a really good slider down and
in outstanding slider from kim and one
of the things he's going to be working
on in this game is getting deeper into
the game he's not been able to go long
yet and again a lot of that has to do
with him
being on the injured list to start the
season
taylor
off the end of the bat and on the
infield
two away so the leadoff double colt wong
still standing there for travis shaw one
ball two strikes with two outs the pitch
a swing enemies shaw strikes out a
leadoff double is wasted by the brewers
wong is left on second luis orios is on
the bat for the crew swinging a foul and
that one got the home plate umpire tony
randazzo that one looked like it got him
right underneath the mask you can feel
this one wherever you're sitting and
watching ouch
right in the middle of the chest
protector and for tony's
nodding in the affirmative that he's
gonna be okay puts the mask on and puts
the other mask on and yadier molina use
the first one to jump to tony's aid
maybe and hopefully just knock the wind
out of it briefly
and oh one pitch
hit in the air center field bader back
onto the warning track makes the catch
one up and one down for the brewers in
the second seventh in a row set down by
freddie peralta back to the top of the
order and tommy edmond 1-1 pitch and
it's off the foot of peralta he says he
has it he feels and tries to scoop
with his glove to sean it's not going to
be there in time that ball was hit right
back up the middle it hit off the foot
of freddie peralta and then scooted over
toward first shaw was going to go get it
peralta said no no i have it freddie's
got a deal with dylan carlson with a man
aboard at first base that was the first
hit allowed by freddie so now he's in
scoring position but one ball and two
strikes here on carlson peralta looks at
second kicks and fires home and did he
go this time yes he did says tony
randazzo
elevated fastball at 94.
carlson couldn't lay off it here's
arenado who's over one he lined out to
right here comes freddy
struck him out slider back-to-back
strikeouts of goldschmidt now arnado
with back-to-back sliders to finish him
and he has six strikeouts in the game
cardinals shift to the right side
against the left-handed hitting shaw
here's a 2-2 pitch and shaw drives this
into right center field that's going to
plug the gap and it'll roll all the way
to the wall for travis shaw
shaw motoring into second with a one-out
double and the brewers have a man in
scoring position here in the bottom of
the fourth oh he's got to be feeling
really good about that especially after
the oo pitch called for a strike really
kind of changing the at-bat out of the
gates and that little spinner just
didn't have the late bite there's manny
pina
back to kim he'll step and throw and
makes the play so that's the second time
that the brewers have a double but
cannot advance the runner was wong in
the first shaw in the fourth we're now
on to the fifth still no score
harrison bader rocks kicks deals swag
and a mess stuck him out
down low and away with a slider
he strikes out harrison vader that is
number eight in the game for freddie
peralta
so one out runner at first peralta will
square again
bunted up in the air and molina cannot
hold on
almost caught it behind his back it
would have been an amazing play it was
an amazing attempt anyway long with a
slightly open stance the pitch that's
hit hard up the middle diving catch by
paul de young he was playing up the
middle and went to the first base side
of second left his feet made the grab at
the edge of the outfield grass
goldschmidt sends this one in the air
first base side
i think it is going to be playable yep
right up against the dugout and caught
by travis shaw only kim's third three
ball count of the night kane a lead off
double at second
fly ball left center slicing away from
bader it's down off the warning track
into the bullpen or ground rule double
kane scores one-nothing brewers
just going gap the gap is travis shaw
last time off drilled a double into
right center field
for freddie peralta he's completed six
innings
twice this season and now tyler o'neil
will be the batter with two away first
pitch to tyler o'neill ground ball deep
in the hole it's short urease fields
throats to second in time seven shutout
innings from fastball freddy so the go
ahead potential go ahead run is at
second base and carlson will bet the 2-2
pitch
from williams is hit in the air to left
field tagging at third is harrison bader
the catch is made and left the throw
coming home and it's not in time the
cardinals have tied it sacrifice fly rbi
dylan carlson is 17th rbi bader scores
and we're tied at 1. billy mckinney on
the mound giovanni gallegos the pitch
there's a solid smash right field coming
on sliding catch by carlson we're going
to the 10th what a play by dylan carlson
sliding grab to take that one right off
the grass
under a third one out now it's goldsmith
first pitch is hammered
out to deep left it's at the wall god
two-run blast for goldie
3-1 st louis
so there's been a lot of traffic in this
11th inning for the cardinals
and that is hammered
into center
at the wall it is gone
tyler o'neal three run blast and i smell
the coffee brewing six to one cardinals
in the 11th the runners lead all the way
around for milwaukee no balls two
strikes two outs the pitch on the way a
swing and a miss for a red bird winner
reyes struck out the side left the bases
loaded the cardinals scored five on the
top of the 11th and turn